How are you Moses?
You look cute.
Thank you, thank you so much.
I'm wearing about four hours worth
of makeup right now.
You love that face did look beat that day.
It did, I've been taking a hit.
You looked great.
You look like you just cyber
bullied some 12 year olds
on call of duty modern.
That's what I'm about.
It's very fitting for Twitch,
this is the look.
I didn't know how weak my sauce was,
until I've had to follow you on stage.
Oh boy, that's so cute of you.
Yeah, like I've lied to hosts before.
I'm like, Oh, I have a thing.
Just so I didn't follow you,
because I went you get up there.
It's impossible to go up
there with my bullshit.
Pretty poor guys.
You do a really great thing,
where you are very present.
You, you talk to the crowd in the moment.
How much of that carried
over to the special,
which is something that's like
his big thing in your mind.
You're like, this is taped forever.
Hmm, I really feel like
it's still carried over.
Like I just really still
tried to stay in the moment.
I think a person that
really helped me with that,
like randomly is Bill Burr.
I had called him like,
maybe four days before
kind of freaking out,
you know what I mean?
Like on some real like
nerd freaking out stuff.
And I was like,
can I send you like the whole thing?
And can you decide to listen to it?
And like, tell me if it's terrible.
And he was like, you don't,
I don't need to do that.
You know what I mean?
Like he was just like kind
of want some chill out,
and he was basically,
he said to me,
the thing that he said
that stuck with me was,
he said, all you're doing is
marking where your set is,
at this moment in time.
That's a really great
way to think about it.
He was like, you're gonna
feel like you miss things,
or you're gonna watch it and be like, Oh,
I should've said that,
or I have this line,
he's like, it's just impossible not to do
that kind of stuff.
But he's like, all you're
doing is marking where your set
is in this moment at this time.
And that's all it is.
And once I kind of
embraced that energy of it,
it took a lot of that
kind of weight off of me,
and allowed me to just be
natural in the way that I am.
And I think it truly did help it all.
Yeah, to be present in that moment.
It is a great way to think about it.
Like, hey listen,
this is where I'm at right now.
And not thinking about,
when will I get another
special after this?
will I be able to tour?
Right, exactly.
You taped a special in
Atlanta versus Boston,
where you're from,
but what was the thought behind that?
I just didn't wanna be
bothered with my family.
I just felt it was too seriously.
It was just too many.
My grandmother had 11 kids.
I grew up there my whole life.
I've got tons of friends,
and I just didn't wanna
be overwhelmed by people.
I wanted to be able to focus
on the thing I had to do.
Yeah, and just performing a fun city.
Did you feel weird about
talking about people on stage,
knowing that they're in the crowd,
like family members,
like, oh, actually this
is how it happened.
It's like, were your version
of what happened not funny.
Right, and no, I don't.
I think the only person
that I'm concerned about,
when it comes to stuff
like that is my girlfriend.
'cause I live with her.
But other than that.
No, don't worry about it.
So have you, if you had
family members reach out
to you and be like, oh,
I'm actually, why did you say this?
And you're just like, I don't care.
I mean, I don't ever put
them in it in a real way.
I have 11 cousins.
So I'll say one of my cousins.
Now that you the guilty party,
then you just know you,
you're the guilty party,
you know what I mean?
I'll say my aunts,
I have seven aunts.
You know like, I don't ever
put a name to the person,
you know, right?
You're not putting people on blast.
No, no, no, I don't put anyone on blast.
I remember a very specific set,
this is when I was like
just getting to know you.
I think it was 2017 Montreal,
which is where comedians would be today.
If this wasn't happening.
It's the biggest comedy festival.
You were part of the new faces,
me and Jack number and the balcony.
And it was very rough,
'cause everyone was bombing
their new faces sets,
as big opportunity you get,
where you basically tell
the world who you are,
you get five minutes,
and it was rough and people
were bombing left and right.
And then you got up there,
and you're supposed to do like
the cleanest version of your set.
Like what would my sit-com be?
And you just started
talking about your divorce,
in a very real way,
and crushed harder than
I've ever seen anyone crush
a new faces set, a credible.
Oh, that's true.
What was the thought going before that?
'Cause I only talked to you after,
I hadn't talked to you before,
of like, was that a fuck it part of you,
or was there like,
this is the only thing
that's gonna work right now.
I mean, one, I was,
that was the set I was gonna do.
That's just what I had
been preparing to do
to go into new faces, and like,
I'm just a firm believer of like,
I can't be doing shit I don't do.
'Cause if I when doing
something I don't do,
that I'm always gonna
have to do that thing,
and I'm gonna be miserable,
and if that's the case,
then I might as well go back to working
at the John Hancock Miller.
So like, why even,
why even set down that road?
So it was kind of like,
I just gonna present this my way,
and like do it how I do it,
because that's the way if I'm gonna win,
I wanna win, you know what I mean?
And I felt like also I was invited,
and you know what I do,
like I haven't changed it up.
So why would you think
I would get on stage,
all of a sudden now
and come out, you know,
talking like I'm some super clean comic,
like that just didn't make sense to me
to approach it that way.
But before, it was nerve wracking,
and people were being crazy.
And I knew that most of those
people were going to bomb.
I've never got to say this publicly,
but I really did.
I knew that most of those
people were going to bomb,
and not because they weren't good,
but because of the energy
that was back in that room,
it was nuts.
Everybody was on edge.
It was the craziest vibe I had ever felt.
I'm like, you can't have
fun on stage like this,
this is insane.
So I left, I left that room,
that they will hold us in.
And I went down to the bar,
and I was drinking,
it just like talking to people
that were like coming in,
and trying to like go sit down and stuff.
And I was just hanging
out treating it like
a regular Thursday night at the improv.
'Cause I was like,
I can't be bothered
with all this craziness.
And I think that helped
like alleviate my brain
of all that nuts stuff.
Like I think that's an important thing,
at least to every any comic watching,
it's like put yourself in the energy
that works for you like.
Don't feel like you have
to sit in that madness,
because it was insane.
Very important that I learned from you.
And one of the only reasons
I got to talk to you,
in the first place,
was that 'cause we have
a lot of mutual friends,
so we do the same shows,
but you always would talk to
just anyone that's around.
And I happened to be anyone,
right before you go on stage.
So you're talking like yourself,
and was like,
so I grew up half Irish and half person.
It's like, no one talks like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and that does help.
It's like, I liked that pace.
Like I liked to be in the
middle of a conversation.
They're like, you're next?
And I'm like, cool.
And I can just let go
up and like do my thing.
I like that pacing of energy,
because it, it does keep
me in the moment, you know?
Have you been out to any of the protests?
No, I have lupus.
So one, I just really
haven't been out much period,
and that wanna really be
riskier out there like that,
so, no I haven't,
but that's just say that if I did it,
I necessarily would be like,
I've gone to them in the past,
and I just find myself
to be more effective in other ways.
Yeah, as far as I think that's
what a lot of, you know,
people with money could do is like, yeah,
put your money where your not, you know,
like insert yourself
into the conversation.
Have you seen any white
cringe allies online?
'Cause I have seen some.
I mean, online is just
all cringe every day.
You know what I mean,
like the whole thing is just like ugh.
Like no one's asking whether,
asking that you stepped in.
Yeah, and also, and also like,
yeah for real.
And also like the explanations of like,
it's like white people are
always annoying with information.
No matter the information,
they're just like annoying information.
And, and it's like just all the research,
that they're newly doing.
And just trying to like,
tell you about yourself a little bit.
It's just like annoying.
And then there's a lot of
moves that I'm like, hmm.
I don't know if we really
cared that much about that.
Like, don't be taking all the flags,
away from the NASCAR people.
Like I get, no car can
have a Confederate flag,
but don't tell people they can't wear one.
One that helps me identify people,
who I should not be around.
If I did go to a NASCAR rally.
It's very easy for me to know, no.
Also as a black person it's unsettling,
Like don't take away all
the white people's like,
these poor white people need something.
Cause you take away
their Confederate flag,
next you know that lynching,
like just let them hold onto
the little piece of whatever they got.
And that's fine, the flag is better,
than murdering a human being.
Right, it's like maybe no,
you can't have it overstay Capitol,
because that state Capitol
represents everybody.
But what the Confederate flag,
the drape over his man
boobs and represent him,
by all means, let him do that.
Absolutely, yeah, the flag
is the helpful reminder.
It's a contact tracing
for racism, of like,
this is the racist person stay away,
from the conversation and
learn about this person.
I love when I see someone
ride by with the flag
of their car and a gun,
it's like don't drive by him, go that way.
Good to know.
So as far as that, I mean,
white people are stepping
down from voiceover jobs,
and your mime was canceled, I mean,
in the bigger picture,
how helpful is that?
Or is that a cop out and like, oh,
I don't have to do anything else,
'cause I did this one thing.
I think it's a little above.
I do think it's helpful
in the sense of like,
I do think it's helpful for
white people being aware of like
my privilege is getting me things,
that other people are
not having access to.
And if I actually want to be helpful,
then I need to recognize that and then,
do something about it and
not just recognize it,
so I do like the action behind it.
But then again, like you're saying,
it goes too far, like we
had to cancel uncle Ben,
and that really messed me up,
because one it's our perception.
I never saw him as a man servant.
I thought he was the
runner of a rice company.
He had a suit on, I was like,
this is the distinguished white man,
that made good rice,
like I really never put
other stank on it, but that,
and I was proud to eat uncle Ben's.
I'm like, look at these supporting Batman,
and it's good rice, but it was,
it was some white people rice.
Right, well, I think
it's for white people.
It's like, well now I don't have to do,
the really uncomfortable
thing as far as like,
standing up for black people in my life.
'Cause I did this one thing
of this thing has nothing
to do with rice that white
people don't even eat,
Uncle Ben has too much seasoning.
Right, that's what I
always felt like it was
the black rice and I had all like
the black stuff in my home.
We had uncle beds, we had,
if it had a black face on it,
we was buying it.
And that was probably the
white man's propaganda.
But I did like having
a black man on my rice.
It's comforting, so I think, yes,
it's sure white people should
not play people that are not,
people of color in voiceover.
But I don't even know about that.
I don't a hundred percent agree with that.
I just think we're at a
time where these things need
to be shifted, and so they're shifting,
but I hope we get to a time where like,
people could just be doing
what they want, you know,
like I think that's the
ultimate goal, like I don't,
I don't think it should be a thing.
Like I was talking to Alex English,
and he was like, well,
I'm tired of straight
actors playing gay actors.
I'm like, well, why can't this is acting?
You know what I mean, I was like,
I think the problem is
there's not enough roles,
and gay people aren't getting roles.
and so it's frustrating,
and then you see a straight
actor playing a role
and you're frustrated,
but I would like to see gay
actors play straight actors,
just straight out it cause it's,
that's the art form.
And a part of why you want to act,
is to be something that you are not,
and portray something that
is not necessarily you.
So we got all the white
people just being white,
and all the black people just being black,
and all the gay people just being gay.
It's about the fuckers
in their actual life.
And we don't really need to see them,
portray or project
anything else, you know?
So I hope we progressed to a place where,
we are a true equality happens,
where we're fine with all that,
because I think we
start to tiff and fight,
over those little things,
because we're not experiencing
equality in our day to day.
And if we were,
then we would care way less
about that kind of stuff.
That is very, very well said.
I mean, yes, I mean that is
a hundred percent agree with that.
The other thing is like,
I've learned this from
touring with like you,
Jack and Chris is like, yes,
do you think it'd be positive,
if comedian white comedians
stepped down from doing
a black scent on stage?
I just think it's dumb
and hacky, so like just,
don't just don't do it 'cause it's stupid.
Anyone not familiar, a
white comedian who looks,
just like me would be like, yeah man.
Y'all already know this is,
what are you doing?
Yeah, just don't do that.
We were in, I think it was San Diego.
And you were just like, no,
from the back of the room,
I think that might actually be helpful.
That might actually be helpful.
This is really great
talking to you, I mean.
It was fun.
I really trust you.
I trust people that have called me a bitch
to my face, right?
I remember once over at Jack's taping,
I was wearing a quilted dress shirt.
One of the many mistakes I've
made and you're like Moses,
you're such a bitch where
quilted dress shirts.
So ever since then and love
you more than anything.
So thank you so much
for doing this though.
Donna's daughter is a, is a
album you already have out.
And then newly three in the morning,
is on Netflix right now.
Sam Jay, thank you so much.
Thanks, bye.